[Music]
this week on
forward but as with everything mosque
it's not simple he's somewhat Mercurial
there's no one simple answer where I can
say is he a Democrat Republican left
right I think you have to read the
evolution that happens over the past 3
years a very closely associated quote is
technology does not automatically
progress which is what a lot of people
think technology does not people think
oh technology is going to get better and
his point is technology does not a
automatically progress it requires human
agency and that's easier for Elon to see
and think because he's literally the
agent musk is not doing his Rockets as a
billionaire boy toy he's not flying up
in the Rockets himself he's actually
Transforming Our ability uh to get into
[Music]
space
it is my distinct privilege and pleasure
to welcome the biographer to the great
Geniuses of our time an author of the
recent authoritative biography on Elon
Musk aply called Elon Musk Walter
Isaacson welcome Walter good to talk to
you again Andrew good to talk to you as
well holy crap man I feel like I've just
found out what you've been doing for the
last two years what was your reaction
when you first realized I guess I'm
going to follow Elon Musk around for two
years you know I was talking to him
because I'd done a book as you know on
Steve Jobs and bringing us to the
digital Revolution then one on Jennifer
dowa who brought us with the
co-invention of crisper the gene editing
technology into the life sciences
Revolution I was looking forward to the
next sort of big Earth shattering things
and to me Elon Musk was doing space
travel and he was bringing us into the a
of electric vehicles and so I talked to
him on the phone we talked for about an
hour and a half at one point and I said
to him if I'm going to do a book I don't
want to do it based on five or 10 or
even 15 interviews I want to be by your
side all meetings all day morning noon
and night for a couple of years any week
I choose to be out with you he said okay
and then I said in the other thing is I
don't want you to have any control over
this book I'm not going to show it to
you in advance you don't get to read it
before published he went okay and I went
down I was telling my wife and friends
that okay you know I'm thinking of doing
this and all of a sudden they're
starting to buzz and I said what
happened he said well he just tweeted
out Walter's writing my biography so
well I guess that's how I knew I was on
the roller coaster wow uh well I thought
it was a master work I learned a lot but
I also actually feel like I grew somehow
I was talking to my wife about it uh all
week uh what has the reaction been and
and I I will say I think there's a lot
of hostility towards Elon among certain
sorts of people um I thought your book
was very fair very objective it felt
like you were uh a fly on the wall or
just like recording events in many cases
um but what has the the reaction been
over the last number of days well I
think it's you I love uh the reactions
to the book as you say he's so
controversial there's some people who
just hate him and you know think okay
how can you write a book about him and
others who think he's like canonize him
and think that he can do no wrong uh and
in general uh sometimes people criticize
well you didn't slam him hard enough or
be too judgmental I think you read the
stories you can make your own judgments
but there's clear the times when he's in
his dark moods and when he does
political things or things he's doing
with the platform that used to be known
as Twitter uh I'm pretty honest and
don't sugarcoat it and I tell Theory
story pretty strong but as you say I
want you to have a feeling reading this
book that it's fastpaced narrative
storytelling that you're right up close
to him and watching him as it's happened
so I'm going to I like the fact that
other people have really strong
judgments in our day and age I think we
get too fast to um canonize or demonize
somebody you know our cable TV and talk
radio are kind of made for people with
really strong opinions but every now and
then I think you got to get a
complicated story uh and certainly Elon
Musk is the most interesting story you
could possibly know right now yeah he
seemed very three-dimensional uh and I I
do think a lot of journalists frankly if
they were given that kind of access
would have quote unquote slammed him and
I thought that you were really really
straight up an objective one of the
major themes of the book was that Elon
might be wired a little bit different
U that than other other folks uh Grimes
uh talked about look I I think that he
might not feel empathy in the same way
that others uh he selfes describes as
having Asbergers SNL makes the same
point uh where they gave him the line
that you quoted saying hey I uh
revolutionized uh space travel and
mainst Street electric vehicles so maybe
I'm not a chill dude um like the the the
rest of you uh and one of the major
themes of the book is maybe it takes
someone with a different type of brain
wiring to do some of the things that
he's done um I I will say on a personal
level I have a child who is neurode
Divergent uh and so he is very very
unmindful of various social norms and
says things that are frankly wholly
inappropriate um now he's 10 so no one
cares but but if you could fast forward
to some point in the future it's
possible that uh you know he he might
continue to be unmindful in a particular
way I want I want to pick up on this
before we move on
because this is one of the most
interesting reactions to my book you've
done it I can tell you 20 or 30 other
people have done it but I haven't talked
about it enough publicly people with
neurode divergent kids as you say who
are on the autism spectrum and certainly
I have a you know people in my family
who are that way they have reacted to
this book in a very deep way because
indeed musk says that he has Asbergers
you know the common phrase sometimes use
for the autism
spectrum uh and he really is not wired
for understanding human emotions well he
talks about having to train himself to
understand emotions and there's I won't
say the name but a TV host you would
know quite well who has a son like that
and he says the only way to make it work
and I'm like thinking of you and your
10-year-old is that this person said my
son's like Elon he just doesn't get the
emotional cues says things that are as
you put it wholly inappropriate at times
but I sit with him we go to the baseball
game together I put my arm around him
and when he does I say when the guy
gives you the popcorn look him in the
eye and say thank you or if somebody
asks you a question try to understand
what they want to hear and try to please
him and he says I do it day in and day
out and it helps him some but I know
he's always going to be different musk
grew up this way with a father who told
him he was stupid who told him he was
useless who whenever musk got beaten up
on the playground which is what happens
when you're Nora divergent or you're
socially awkward he get his face
pummeled and then he'd have to stand in
front of his father who would take the
side of the person who beat him up
and so this doesn't excuse Elon I'm
trying to tell you the narrative and
people say well you're trying to justify
his way I'm saying no no no I'm trying
to explain to you who he is and yeah he
shouldn't do things that are totally
inappropriate but I tell you I've been
surprised by the
quiet meaningful feedback I have with
people who have people in their families
who say things as you put it who are
inappropriate for the moment or aren't
catching the social cues and for elon's
case it's pretty bad he has a son too
Saxon delightful kid in the book very
wise he always quotes but Saxon is
autistic and always has to have a minder
or somebody with him and uh it's weird
in this day and age when you do a
narrative like
this you're on the borderline of
explaining but not necessarily excusing
the inappropriate Behavior but I do
think I try to let the reader go deep
the way you just did
Andrew imagine running for president and
wanting to share what you experienced in
a way that's entertaining edifying and
maybe even a little bit scary that's the
last election out in bookstores now a
novel about an independent presidential
candidate a journalist with a mass story
and what the heck could be our nextlast
election check it out at andrewyang.com
[Music]
I think you did a really effective job
and certainly having uh a son who's
autistic uh gave me a different
perspective um one of the the major
themes I thought uh that the book book
delved into there there's this point in
the book when um Elon sues the
government or sues NASA over awarding
contracts uh in an incentives plus
structure uh which is hey loed Martin or
Boeing uh take on this project and then
you can add 20% as a profit margin
regardless of whether it is successful
or not and then Elon actually Sues and
says hey that's not the way you can
award contracts which anyone advises
would say that's insane to sue the US
government uh and somehow he wins and
then when the contracts are then dealt
out based upon who can perform a task
they end up or uh SpaceX ends up getting
the contracts and then
leapfrogging uh the other players um
that there's a a consistent theme about
Elon kind of flouting rules breaking
rules pushing the the boundaries in some
ways that again people would find
totally
inadvisable in a lot of context um but
that
particular uh incentive switch ends up
being literally the key to spacex's
success but then the key to America's
success in getting astronauts back into
orbit you know 50 years ago we sent
people to the moon and then we gave up
we didn't go back 12 or so years ago we
grounded the space shuttle and since
then haven't been able to get astronauts
from the US to the space station uh and
what you put your finger on once again
you put your finger on some other
interviewers have not yet talked about
which is it seems minor but it's huge
which is not only has he built rockets
that can send mass and astronauts in
orbit and can land and be reused which
no country or company has done have
reusable Rockets but he moved us from
Cost Plus Contracting which you
described which is take all the time you
want and whatever it costs you will give
you that plus a profit this is why
Boeing became flabby this is why NASA
was not able to get astronauts into
orbit and he said no give me a mission
tell me a fix price and then in the book
you see him walking through the assembly
line day after day saying how do we make
this valve a little bit less expensive
or this part of the nose cone a little
bit lighter and he ends up being able to
accomplish the missions at onet the cost
of a Boeing or lockade and Boeing and
musk and Boeing had both gotten after
this contracts to get astronauts to the
space station around the same time musk
has had like 33 missions now sending
things into orbit and multiple missions
to the space station Boeing and NASA
have yet to be able to do a success test
flight that gets astronauts up so moving
us into the era of fixed fee for service
rather than Cost Plus Contracting it
sounds like something only a geek like
me and you could appreciate but it's
part of the big deal oh yeah I mean I I
I understood the that if you change the
incentives you actually have a real
chance um and there are unfortunately a
lot of other areas in American life
where I think the incentives um are are
messed up I'm going to random share a
story because Richard Branson makes a
cameo um in your book I was with Richard
last year and he talked about his Maiden
flight into space uh and he talked about
how the rocket doesn't have a bathroom
um so he wore a diaper uh uh on the
maiden flight um but he didn't want
wearing the diaper on the first trip to
be his only time using the diaper so he
put the diaper on the day
before then just tried it out to see if
it work worked um so he he was sharing
the kind of uh detail about you know
some of the less glamorous elements um
uh of uh space travel there's this
tension between the public sector and
billionaires now uh in American Life uh
you used to be the head of Time Magazine
by the way I had a friend who worked for
you during that time and and people
thought very well of you now time is
owned by uh Mark bennof who I believe is
a billionaire billionaires own a lot of
the major media companies
elon's obviously a billionaire um and it
seems like there are these gaps in what
the public sector can and can't do and
so people are turning to billionaires
but then they hate turning to
billionaires because there's a real
problem with the this notion that you
need a billion dollars to get anything
done in in American Life uh I I feel
like this is one of the things that your
book touches on in various ways is that
there's something garish obviously about
uh commercial space travel being a
billionaire uh sandbox
um but then if we waited for the public
sector to do it we might be waiting
forever well let's uh make clear that
even though Elon Musk went and was with
Branson when Branson took his flight
musk is not doing his Rockets as a
billionaire boy toy he's not flying up
in the Rockets himself he's the only
person who can get our us intelligence
satellites into high Earth orbit the
only person who's been able to uh you
know send up almost 5,000 satellites to
recreate the internet and outer space
and if you look this year
alone I think he will launch maybe 1,600
tons of payload and satellites into
orbit that's more than every other
country meaning China Russia the United
States and every other company combined
not only that it's four times as much as
every other company and Country combined
so it's not just a Billionaire's Boy Toy
here he's actually Transforming Our
ability uh to get into
space this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a pretty short list of things
you can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress order ERS and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now so I will say people probably know
this but Elon uh did endorse me during
my presidential run last time I think
his exact quote was I like Yang which I
appreciated I did meet him and Grimes um
I'm a huge Grimes fan I thought that she
was a lovely human
and we yeah and and uh she actually has
preceded you uh on this podcast um so I
I feel like you were witnessed to a lot
of um uh family uh events um now the
perception of Elon seems to have been um
transformed by his recent takeover of
Twitter now X um and when I I talked to
my wife about Elon buying Twitter um I
had a very very bad feeling um and and I
I'll explain my bad feeling like this um
I've got 1.6 million followers on
Twitter um Elon has about a 100 times as
many he has like
159 um million followers and my wife
feels bad for me that I'm on Twitter and
I'm imagining like an alternate world
where Elon not only didn't buy X but
just wasn't X at all um I I have a
feeling that uh we'd be in a very we'd
be thinking of him very differently um
if he was never on X 100% I think that's
totally true and I think it's a shame
that he both bought X he has a friend um
named Antonio close friend and they were
traveling once and musk just in the
middle of the night maybe with a little
bit too much red bull or ambian uh was
always tweeting out these things which
you know doesn't help his reputation
amongst a lot of people and the friend
put the uh phone his phone in the safe
in the hotel room and put in a code so
Elon couldn't get it late at night Elon
called hotel security at 3: in the
morning and made him open the safe he's
addicted to sending out tweets my book I
try not to go down the rabbit hole too
much of Twitter it was I think is not a
great um move for him he doesn't have
the emotional receptors that might
create the type of happy environment
you'd want for advertisers and as Kimble
his brother says you know Twitter will
just be a pimple on his
reputation I think people have to
understand uh Twitter but they have to
understand all the other things he does
especially the move into artificial
intelligence which will truly transform
our lives and Optimus the robot which
will'll be able to see and hear here and
be able to navigate in the world and
getting back to you Andrew one of the
reasons he supported you is he thinks
artificial general
intelligence and what he's doing with
Optimus the robot will transform work so
much that he's in favor of a universal
basic income even though he has nowadays
what I would call more populist um
sentiments on the right he still
believes that we do need to trans form
work uh by having not only artificial
intelligence but Robotics and
self-driving cars and self-driving
trucks and then we should take the
proceeds from that and have at least
some form of uh Universal basic income
yeah he he has spoken about that um both
uh during my campaign and and since then
uh and we share a lot of the concerns um
about uh AI so you can tell I kind of
wish he wasn't on
Twitter like your wife feels bad about
you oh yeah my my wife feels bad for me
and I I I appreciate um that that that
about her so Elon very controversially
uh cut 75% of uh the employees of
Twitter and then there were a lot of
folks who said hey that's going to be
too deep to the Bone they're going to
have it's going to collapse uh was the
critique um it had some problems but it
has not collapsed um and it ended up
spurring a mega Trend among tech
companies actually cutting staff I don't
know if you were aware of that you
probably
are that other boards and investors said
hey guys like look over there they just
cut 75% so you should at least be able
to cut 30% so I I I feel like that was a
move that only Elon would have made but
it it does have profound repercussions
in my mind one of the things that Beyond
Tech because one of the things that I've
been saying to folks is look if you move
to remote work um you're moving a lot of
workers is more towards being automated
and becoming um Irrelevant in their orgs
like when we were all in the same place
like when you were running time everyone
came together and you chewed over ideas
uh and and uh um it sometimes had a real
impact on the stories but now if you
move everyone to remote then it ends up
being easier to cut a disembodied Avatar
than it is a human that you literally
see every day do you think that um that
uh elon's person moves will end up um
causing a trend that extends Beyond Tech
well he was right that you could cut 75
80% of the people at Twitter and he has
a philosophy which is Allin hardcore if
you're going to work here uh a fierce
sense of urgency is our operating uh
principle and there are other workplaces
that do it differently I can remember
Time magazine in the old days where you
know we took Mondays and Tuesdays off
and had a drinks cart coming down on
closing night uh and I think people have
to choose do I want to be in a hardcore
environment where you know hackathon and
sometimes staying up all night do I want
a more pleasant work life balance and I
think in America it's really good that
we have both opportunities two types of
places he turned Twitter the company
from being one of the most nurturing
sweet places to being a hardcore Allin
intense place there's a whole chapter
called Allin in the book and uh you can
like that or you can hate that but we
have to understand that those are the
choices not only employers make but
those of us who are employees get to
sometimes choose what type of place we'd
prefer to work the more complicated
issue which you've wrestled with is when
you make a
company uh have a reduced Workforce and
they're more efficient they can still
get it done with you know 20% of the
workers 30% of the workers when you do
that across the board and the companies
are doing that does that actually reduce
the total amount of unemployment in the
society or in some ways does it increase
productivity and you end up overall
disrupting some jobs but having more
employment in a society and I think
there's a too simplistic of a view which
is if companies lay people off they'll
end up increasing the total amount of
Unemployment uh the data points don't
really show that I mean if Automation
and Robotics
were decreasing the total number of jobs
unemployment would be real high now
because we have a lot of that so
productivity at a place like Twitter or
at a place any other place you want to
name name may be the best way to keep
employment up but we also have to be
sensitive to both the needs the desires
and really the spiritual well-being of
people who work at
places um sounds like time was a great
place to work when you were there Walter
yeah know the drinks card every Thursday
and Friday night yeah people are hearing
that description and are like oh man uh
sign sign me up for
that
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you so I I'm around young people a lot
and there's like a very very real
emphasis culturally on young people of
Community taking care of each other
kindness uh um that kind of collegiality
and then I I think one of the reasons
why Elon encounters a lot of hostility
is that his stuff seems to fly in the
face of that in many ways it it's very
much
Mission uh hardcore as you you describe
it um there are times when he's
blatantly unfair to some of his reports
and you have painstaking accounts of of
some of those uh the person who ran
Solar City um which is put in in what
sounded like an impossible position um
he pretty much names an engineer as
being at fault when it's not the
engineer's fault it turns out that it
was the humidity uh and the launch site
that ended up um causing the issue but
there's obviously no shortage of people
that want to work for Elon because he's
got an incredible Mission set and track
record but also he's created so much
value that if you become part of these
organizations there's a chance that you
get very very uh Rich um pretty quickly
so in a way he can afford to be himself
I guess more Mission oriented and
hardcore and brus because then that
there is no shortage uh of people um do
you feel like those two things and this
is one of the themes of the book is that
uh and there are people by the way that
work for Elon That Then Say Hey like I
can't work for Elon because this is
totally not the way I I do things um
they probably would have been quite
happy at Time Magazine under your
tenure
um do do you think that there is like a
a tension between some of the emphasis
on uh collegiality and manners versus
this hardcore Mission orientation yeah I
think so and musk talks about in the
book I I'm a real believer in
collegiality and I think I if you knew
people work with me at time you say they
enjoyed it because I tried to make it
enjoyable and collegiality is a good
thing and certainly being empathetic to
your employees is a good thing but as
Steve Jobs said to me and then Elon Musk
said to me because they were both more
hardcore Allin he said sometimes being
nice ends up being self-indulgent in a
leader meaning they care too much about
what the two or three people in front of
them are feeling and they want everybody
to like them and they lose sight of the
hardcore mentality have to have in order
to achieve the mission and so by being
nice to a few people around you or who
happens to walk into your office you
making yourself feel good it's being
self-indulgent to you and not just the
person in front of you but maybe there
are thousands of people who aren't going
to do as you know things are not going
to go as well because you've lost sight
of the mission you're just trying to
please everybody and my own personal
example I think I was pretty good at
running Time Magazine it was a very
flush period we were making a lot of
money I knew everybody on the staff I
didn't have to be disruptive as you may
recall I then moved to CNN and I sat
there caring about every you know being
making sure that you know Lou dos and gr
anustan and uh and everybody was feeling
good and probably I should have been
more of a disruptor I should have had
more of the mission in mind and been
tougher as a boss in fact I ended up
being pushed that way after the War the
Gulf War is like okay now you got to
make Cuts now you got to be tougher I
said you know what that's not me and I
left CNN went to the Aspen Institute you
got to look into side yourself but you
also have to realize that from the
perspective of a Steve Jobs or an Elon
Musk or Bill Gates in the early days of
Microsoft or a Jeff
Bezos that being
self-indulgent in
terms of wanting and being needy enough
to want everybody to to love you that's
a good thing up to a point but not if
you lose sight of the hardcore way you
need to pursue the mission in order for
the Enterprise to succeed and survive
yeah reading this book made me reflect
on my own nature uh Walter I imagin
myself to be a fairly uh collegial
human the same time um when I was
running for president
um I put my all into it um and was um
hardcore in some ways I mean I don't
think I ever um was unduly you know a
jerk uh to those around me because I was
trapped in a rental vehicle with them
and I discovered pretty quickly that if
I was a jerk to them it just ruined the
whole
day because they're still at the rental
vehicle but it it it made me even dwell
on my own balance you know like do I uh
have there been times when um maybe I
should have been more hardcore and
Mission oriented like you know like that
that that's the kind of impact the book
had on me yeah I mean and I as I said I
think I felt that way a little bit uh
coming out of CNN which is I had to
figure out who I am and I'm not as I
mean I've talked to a lot of people who
worked for mosque and they said I was
all in in hardcore especially in my 20s
and 30s but now I want to work life
balance and I'm moving on but I was out
in Los Angeles about four or five days
ago and uh there's a person in my book
uh from the launch site down in southern
Texas and musk just goes ballistic on
them one late Friday night because only
a few people are working at the launch
pad and mus says we got to be all in we
got to be we'll never get to Mars unless
we have an all-in intensity and he
orders up a surge and people and this
guy learned learns how to survive it
understands how to deal with musk ends
up getting promoted even though he gets
reamed out but then when he's having a
kid he says all right you know I'm no
longer Allin I'm no longer hardcore I
admired that and then in Los Angeles
he's walking up to me after some event
said hey how are you what you doing he
says I'm missing it I got to get back I
got to get back to SpaceX cuz I had a
choice of being burned out or being
bored
I think I'd rather be burned out in
pursuit of the mission so we all have
different values at different times in
our
lives this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use express VP
PN it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use express VP n
secure your online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com slang today that's
expressvpn.com yangang and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
so a number of years ago people would
think of Elon as kind of uh green a
little bit bit left of center he was an
Obama supporter um and then over the
last number of years I think some people
think of him as actually kind of
conservative uh
reactionary um I have a sense that part
of that is because he's been attacked by
certain people and there's a natural
tendency that if you get attacked by a
certain group of people then you say
okay like I guess uh whoever doesn't
like you I guess I'm with them and I I I
personally uh you know see that as a
problem of
polarization um that there is this
uh US versus them left versus right
Dynamic um I I've been U frankly I think
I've been attacked by both
sides but um but what is your perception
as to um whether uh Elon uh actually
belongs that that conventional Left
Right Dynamic whether he's uh somewhat
uh independent uh or uh just like you
know intellectually not really um
ideological or easily categorized yeah
he's hard to characterize you're right
and in the book you'll see it in the
narrative the slow evolution of him
being what I would call almost a
traditional Center left you know
supporter of Obama supporter of
Democrats and he moves to a position
that's hard to put a label on but it's
basically I wouldn't say conservative
it's kind of Pop populist right
pugnacious uh and sometimes you're
believing in things I would call
conspiracy theories uh he doesn't spout
them too much but he lets him back on
the platform that used to be known as
Twitter and he'll retweet people or like
or say interesting or wow and so there's
part of him that has moved to that area
partly it's a reaction to Democrats just
just attacking him all the time and
Elizabeth Warren saying you know he
doesn't pay taxes way should when he had
in fact that year paid more tax than any
other human has ever paid to any entity
in history uh and it's partly a personal
thing in the book which he felt that his
daughter became so infected by what he
called the woke M virus that she hated
billionaires and hated capitalism and
changed her last name and wouldn't speak
to him and it's partly a reaction to I
think what he felt was too honorous of
shut Downs uh during coid so the
evolution in the book you see it happen
but as with everything
mosque it's not simple he's somewhat
Mercurial I can speak to him in the
middle of the day sometimes when I was
writing this book and he talked about
the need for moderates and having a
Centrist party having a pack supporting
people in the center and then sometimes
he'd be on just a you know a Jag about
woke wokeness or something so as with
everything he does he's
variable I do think uh it's a reason a
lot of people don't like him is this
political Evolution had he not spoken
about politics had he not tweeted things
had he not bought Twitter had he not
gone down to the southern border and
shown videos of people trying to get
across the Rio
Grand I think he would be a lot you know
wouldn't wouldn't be a lightning rod
wouldn't have so many people but it's
part of who he is as he gets worked up
about things there's no one simple
answer where I can say is he a Democrat
Republican left right I think you have
to read the evolution that happens over
the past three years now that it's
fascinating I think a lot of the
response now and the way I see politics
is there's like this um
anti-institutional energy that takes
various forms and I feel like Elon has
been attacked by various institutions
and so he he has come across as kind of
anti-institutional but he hates the
mainstream media and he thinks he's
always been attacked in the great old
institutions and I do remind him that I
think I may be the poster boy for the
old line old-fashioned establishment
media having spent my time at Time
Magazine and uh CNN but he laughs about
that well he he gave you a personal
exemption
Walter I don't know I just sit there in
the corner I'm letting everybody go for
the ride everybody gets to I think he's
fascinating as well as controversial and
I think it's useful to just watch him
and form your own judgments you know
when I come out of Louisiana they're
either preachers or
storytellers and I had a mantor Tell Me
For Heaven's Sake be a Storyteller this
world's got too many preachers so some
of the the big quotes toward the tail
end of the book are from Elon I think
that they really summarize some of the
things you and I are are talking about
um I'm sure you've heard this over and
over again from folks uh um who've
interview in the book um but Elon says
this is how civilizations decline they
quit taking risks and when they quit
taking risks their arteries Harden every
year there are more referees and fewer
doers when you've had success for too
long you lose the desire to take risks
uh and then a a very closely associated
quote is technology does not
automatically progress which is what a
lot of people think technology does
not people think oh technology is going
to get better and his point is
technology does not automatically
progress um uh it requires human agency
and that's easier for Elon to see and
think because he's literally the agent
um but I I think that there's a very
very important observation there that
this stuff is not
automatic yeah you know we got to the
Moon 50 years ago and then we quit going
to the moon and quit going anywhere else
we had a space shuttle that used to take
astronauts into orbit and it was risky
it actually as you know it was risky it
exploded but then we quit doing it and
now NASA has no way to get astronauts to
the space station which is why SpaceX
has to do it well Nation
Andrew of people with risk-taking
ingrained into their character whether
you came over on the Mayflower or you
came from Europe escaping oppression or
from Venezuela or you came across the
Rio Grand people took
risks and now I think musk is right why
are we not taking Great Adventures why
are we so paralyzed whether it be with
the clown show in Congress or our
inability to manufacture things in
America that well I think that Alon musk
takes a few too many risks I think he
needs a few more guard rails but I think
he's right that we've become sclerotic
Our arteries have hardened as a nation
because there are more people making
rules and
regulations than innovating they're more
referees and uh Regulators more lawyers
more people saying you can't do that or
probably be a good idea not to do that
and he has a five-step algorithm whether
he's making a rocket or making a car
which is step one question every rule
question every regulation there's no
rule that's unbreakable other than the
laws of physics and then you know it
goes on that you simplify and you
question everything we got to be able to
get back to that instead of saying okay
we can design a few cool things and then
we send them off to other countries to
manufacture that has messed up our
economy and messed up our pride as a
nation and one of the things I mean we
talked about musk being good at changing
us from Cost Plus contracts to risk
contracts I think the other thing that's
important is he's moved manufacturing
whether it's batteries or cars or rocket
ships back to the United States and
shows that we can actually do it well I
couldn't agree with you more Walter
here's to taking some more risks
innovating being less sclerotic maybe
not Elon level risks but uh you know
like a healthy amount of risk because at
this point we need a balance you're
right and the book shows and by the way
we need Regulators I'm glad there's a
highway Transportation safety board
looking into things cuz he would be out
of control without guard rails but we
also don't need more people making too
many more people who make guard rails
than we have making Innovations well I
did go to law school and then I I left
the practice after five months because I
I didn't want to be negative throughout
my entire
20s not knock the lawyers I mean
Shakespeare can do that but we can uh I
want lawyers to enjoy this book too well
everyone should read this book because I
I think that they'll um actually learn
about The Human Condition uh and also
about what it may take to improve our
circumstances as a species Walter
congratulations on an awesome
achievement Elon Musk you certainly
don't need my plug because I think it's
literally like one of the best selling
books of all time already um but it it's
an accomplishment to be proud of um and
I hope you get a little bit of a break
oh yeah I'm having a good old time I'm
back home in New Orleans and thank you
so much for what you said about the book
Andrew
[Music]